au moment d'accueillir marc-antoine le
bret qui est avec nous merci
marc antoine le grand piano noir bonsoir
marc-antoine merci d'être là vous venez
nous donner des nouvelles des stars du
paf et il paraît que vous avez des
nouvelles de franck dubosc et non tu
n'as pas revello dire c'est bien moi
franck dubosc à chair en os et en jean
claude cyr il j'ai vu des audiences et
je peux te dire qu'on fait tous les deux
la même chose ouais on donne du plaisir
aux ménagères d'ailleurs cyril tu sais
ce que je dirais une femme après son 5e
orgasme
je lui dis ne bouge pas mais bien
j'arrive je raccroche mon téléphone
il ya des dieux ni bronner comme il va
parce qu'il ya kho lanta ils sont en
train de tourner ses amis aventuriers je
reviens prochainement avec de nouveaux
candidats
valérie trierweiler parviendra-t-elle à
rallumer la flamme de françois ou
devra-t-elle étendre son flambeau
michelle obama succombera-t-elle à la
terrible épreuve
je ne sais plus quoi
donald jeune nageuse et que vous l'avez
bien aussi parce qu'il est sympathique
c'est cyril lignac saleh chérif saisir
j'adore ton prénom j'adore touche pas à
mon poste c'est une émission est bien
gourmand des gains grocam au quotidien
comme un bien qu'aucun chimay gotha non
dans l'émission gars gilles verdez je
peux vous dire que les commentaires de
gilles verdez si comme le piment
d'espelette
ces pics angle ça peut être dur à
digérer et pour certains ça fait mal au
cul moi je suis pas du tout d'accord
avec mika est génial
alors franchement je vais pas le dire
mais mika c'est une chèvre voilà il vous
fait bien c'est pas vous reconnaissez ou
pas jacques lefrère bah ouais il est
content au regard des icônes nicolas
bedos aussi beaucoup là il est beaucoup
chez ruquier
salut c'est bedos le seul le vrai celui
qui lit pas momifié alors voilà mon cher
cyril je suis venu avec mes notes quart
à sens mon texte je suis comme bernardo
d'en haut
je n'ai pas de répartie ainsi donc mon
chien cyril malgré mon fiel tu as dit de
bien de moi et si donc voilà by presque
frère nonobstant mon physique de rêve
celui de vendeur de tour eiffel dont
mère-nature ta jadis affublé karoui
civile je t'ai entendu prendre ma
défense dans ton émission qu'on se serre
yannick heures de jean michel maire me
reprocher de ne parler que de moi moi
aussi je me cherchais t-il des noises
lui qui n'a que ça tombe à la bouche
jean-michel quelle souplesse
bref hier cyril nous voilà maintenant
amis et je le dirai donc plus de mal de
toi
pas plus que le ton rire de yann
asthmatique et encore moins les tons
physique de gipsy kings cathodique
voilà merci nicolas
c'est la belle et la bête vincent cassel
ouais c'est vincent cassel qu'est-ce qui
va bon feeling j'ai dit était à la télé
et que tu parlais que le télé j'ai dit
ça à la télé tu sais de quoi je parlais
à la télé de télé et je peux te dire que
j'adore regarder la télé mais seulement
quand elle éteinte comme ça je peux voir
mon reflet dedans et ça c'est plus beau
spectacle du monde
la pression il est il arrivé incroyable
et puis on a un dernier alors oui il a
jamais est limité 1re série des coups ce
soir c'est qu'evans qualificatif les
mecs à 17 ans puis cinq ans tu l'as bien
tu eu la garde
sinon franchement je te kiffe grave il
ferait trop qui viennent avec moi dans
ma série soda jouer dedans sérieux et en
parlant de soda ou vous êtes chant pas
la joue pas rajaona ça le charme il est
gras d'hélium tu veux savoir si sérieuse
en voile ou 20 8 12
cabanac et villagrains
bas depuis six mois